cool
so hello everyone welcome to day two of
NDC how's it going so far we're about
the halfway mark everyone enjoying it
it's good to be back in person right
um this is my first time speaking at NDC
it's also my first time out of the
country since so out of New Zealand
sorry
um since January 2020 so I've got like a
double excited thing going on I'm like
the dog like putting his head out the
car window so I'm very excited to be
joining you all today my name is will
the leader I'm a customer engineer
working in the fast track for Azure team
at Microsoft and part of my role is
working alongside Engineers to help them
build robust applications in Azure my
focus is really on app development and
modernization so I work with Engineers
to provide them with architectural
guidance Deep dive sessions on
serverless and container Technologies
helping them Implement build pipelines
develop their devops purposes and so
much more uh and today we're going to be
talking about developing and deploying
containers and microservices with Azure
container apps so just to go through
kind of the agenda of what I'm going to
talk about today we'll start by going
over a very high level overview of what
Azure container apps is and what type of
applications we can build of them
then we'll dive a little bit deeper into
the features of container apps and I'll
talk about how we can actually use those
features to develop and build our
applications for container apps and then
I've got a couple of demos where I'll
show you different ways where we can get
started with container apps so basically
provisioning container apps and then
I'll start evolving those Demos in to
show you how that works with CI CD how
we can actually build out container
images and deploy them to container apps
many in GitHub actions but the
principles that I'll show you are
applicable to other platforms as well
such as Azure devops and gitlab
so let's dive in so let's start with a
very high level of what Azure container
apps actually is
so who here just a question to kind of
start off here uh who here kind of works
day to day with kubernetes doesn't have
to be Azure kubernetes service can be
eks gcp even on-prem okay so a couple of
you
kubernetes is hard
we constantly see lots of Engineers and
customers come to us saying look we're
looking to modernize our applications
we've got this massive monolith and we
want to break it up into several
different microservices and we've heard
about this thing called kubernetes and
we like the sound of it and it's like
okay sounds sounds good how much
experience do you have with kubernetes
none and it's like ah okay all right the
because kubernetes can be complex
particularly to those who are new to
kubernetes this is a blocker for lots of
Engineers to be able to adopt containers
and microservices architecture
and what Azure container apps tries to
tries to do is essentially
allow developers to focus on their
applications rather than worry about the
underlining container orchestrator
infrastructure
it's built on top of azure kubernetes
service and it also comes with built-in
support for cada so kubernetes event
Driven Auto scaling Envoy and it has
Integrations with Dapper and essentially
provides you with opinionated services
so you can not worry about what you're
going to plug into kind of your
microservices architecture but you can
just focus on your application
development
come on slides
there we go awesome so like I said
container apps is built on top of Open
Source technology so it runs on
kubernetes Azure kubernetes service
um Ikeda Dapper and Envoy and since it's
built on top of these Technologies it
allows you to kind of take advantage of
what those of the capabilities of those
platforms so you have built-in service
Discovery for your microservices you
have fully managed support for hdp HTTP
to Ingress Etc and this gives us the
advantage to be able to perform the
common application of life cycle tasks
such as upgrading applications splitting
traffic between different versions in a
much more simpler way than if we had to
manage the orchestrator infrastructure
ourselves
and because you're not burdened by it
um you could spend more time building
the services that you want to build for
your customers and with container apps
we can build microservices we can deploy
apis onto it event processing workers
background jobs all using containers
using any programming language that we
want or any framework that we like to
just another question how many of you
have used Azure functions in the past
before we using it now okay most of you
are that's cool so that kind of the
difference between Azure functions and
container apps um container apps
provides us with a little bit more
developer flexibility
there's no enforcement of a programming
model so when you're developing your
functions there is a kind of a program
model that is enforced onto you and
there's also like a limited amount of
languages that you can use within Azure
functions if you're using languages like
go or rust there are custom handlers but
there's better support for languages
like C sharp python Java Etc
whereas container apps you haven't got
those limitations so if you can
containerize your application you can
deploy it to Azure container apps with
the caveat of they have to be Linux
based container images there's no
support for Windows content how many of
you are using Windows containers don't
be shy a couple of you okay
I don't know when or if they'll ever be
support for Windows containers on Azure
container apps
so sorry about that
um but yeah there's uh if you can
containerize and deploy to Linux you're
good to go on Azure container apps
um and then thanks to kind of
integration with uh Dapper which is the
distributed application runtime not the
orm Dapper
um you can simplify common tasks that
you would in any microservices
architecture such as pubsav service
invocation and event processing
container apps provides like a Paz way
of being able to deploy your Dapper
applications where in the past you were
kind of limited if you were developing
applications using the Dapper framework
you were limited to something like Azure
kubernetes service
excellence and then container apps also
provides
kind of robust ability to scale on a
variety of different things so under the
hood it uses cada so it uses CAD event
scale triggers or CPU and memory or HTTP
triggers to kind of Auto scale and you
can run your containers and scale in
response to say HTTP traffic or any kind
of cada supported scale trigger that
that platform of that sorry open source
project provides
so that's kind of like a very high level
overview of what container apps is let's
start to kind of explore what we can
actually build with container apps so
really kind of the first class kind of
like citizen on container apps is really
microservices architecture the idea is
that the platform is there to kind of
support developers who are building
microservices but don't want to use
kubernetes to kind of have a platform
that they can easily deploy their
containers to
there's also you can also build public
apis and web apps on Azure container
apps as I'll show you in a demo so you
can actually enable HTTP Ingress onto
your container apps and make them
publicly available and we can actually
Scale based on how many HTTP requests
are coming into our container container
apps as well
we can also build event-driven
processing um workloads inside container
apps so say if you've got a container
app that's listening to messages coming
from a queue we can scale our container
apps based on how many messages are
incoming into um into our queue and we
can also do some background processing
um what we can provision background
processing workloads as well on some
container apps the amount of times I've
seen customers and Engineers try to
force Azure functions to do these kind
of long-running background processing
tasks it can get quite painful and quite
um
quite a bit of a nightmare to to manage
because that's not what it's designed
for it's designed for particularly like
normal functions there's durable
functions like yeah
um but for kind of like normal functions
that's more designed for kind of like
quick reacting to Quick events
um so it's not designed for that so
container apps it's more suitable for
for those kind of background processing
tasks
now before we dive a little bit deeper
into Azure container apps I do want to
make the comparison with AKs because the
purpose for of me standing here today
I'm not here to tell you okay there's no
need for Azure kubernetes service or any
kubernetes deployment ever go back to
your workplaces and destroy your classes
that's not the goal here
the main focus of the main trade-off
between something like Azure kubernetes
service and Azure container apps is
really the the trade-off between
flexibility and productivity
if you need to be more selective about
what your how you're extending your
cluster and what kind of add-ons you're
putting on into your kubernetes
environment Azure kubernetes services
are great great choice for you
um
if you don't really want to worry about
managing the infrastructure of your
container orchestrator and you don't
want to deal with the complexity
Azure container apps is a good option
for you
bear in mind that with Azure container
apps if you're running Cube control
commands against your kubernetes
clusters that's not going to be
supported
um with you for you in Azure container
apps
cool so let's dive a little bit deeper
into some of the main concepts of azure
container apps
so we start off with a container apps
environment
individual container apps are deployed
to a single container apps environment
now for those of you coming from
kubernetes you can really think of this
as like a namespace
and this acts as like a secure boundary
around groups of your container apps
container apps in the same environment
are deployed to the same virtual Network
and they write logs to the same log work
log analytics workspace
when you provision a container app
environment a v-net acts as the boundary
and you kind of have two options if you
just want to deploy an environment a
v-net is automatically created for you
but that belongs or that lives sorry in
our tenant so you don't have any
visibility of that v-net we take care of
that and we look after it for you on
your behalf
however if you have an existing v-net or
if you want to create a custom v-net
that you like to deploy your content
apps environment to
um you can do that and that's created in
your subscription your environment and
then you can take care of that
now inside our environments are the
container apps themselves and simply put
this is just kind of like a single
independent microservice that includes
our desired State configuration for our
container app
and in there are the actual containers
so container apps manages the details of
kubernetes and container orchestration
for you
and containers can like I said earlier
uh use any runtime any programming
language and any development stack of
your choice there's support for Linux
based container images
you can pull containers from any public
or private container registry so if
you're using a private container
registry such as um Azure container
registry you can build and um
a problem and store your images in
container registry and then configure
your container apps to pull images from
your container registry into your
container app
the caveat here with container apps is
it can't run privileged containers or
any processes that require root access
that's a limitation of azure container
apps today you can't do that
there's no required base container image
and if your container crashes underneath
the hood the container will container
app will automatically restart for you
now one pattern that you can use with
your containers you can Define multiple
containers within the same container app
and this means they'll be co-located and
scaled together this the purpose of this
is not to run multiple microservices
within a single container app this is
more suited for kind of those sidecar
scenarios where the sidecar containers
are running alongside your core workload
container
and then we have this idea of revisions
so this is where we start to get into
okay how do we actually deploy different
versions of our container app and how do
we manage traffic between different
versions of our container app a revision
is an amusable snapshot of our container
app
now in container apps we kind of have
two modes of how we can actually manage
revisions we can have a single revision
mode which is the default or multiple
revision mode and I'll explain the
difference between those um
those in a second
so take the following like example so
when we first provision our container
app revision is automatically created
for us
and as we make changes to the container
apps template configuration and these
can include changes by like the
environment variables that we use how
much CPU and memory
um we're allocating to those containers
the container image itself or image
we're actually using for our container
app new revisions will be automatically
created
now revisions are immutable but if we
make changes on a global configuration
scale it's going to apply to all of our
revisions so for example if I'm using
secrets in my container apps and I'm
changing the values of those Secrets all
of the revisions within my container app
are going to be affected by that secret
change so say for example you've got a
secret that's got a connection string to
a database
if a previous version of your app was
using an older secret pointing to a
different database and you change that
your older revision is going to point to
your new connection string through your
database so it's just something to keep
in mind
the power behind revisions is this is
really
um useful when you enable Ingress or to
make your container apps accessible via
http
and in the demo that I'll show in a
little bit later
revisions we often use revisions for
direct traffic between one revision and
another and this opens up some really
powerful deployment scenarios such as a
b testing and blue green deployments
so just to kind of like summarize the
differences between revision scope and
application scope changes revision scope
changes are changes that we make to the
template of our container app so this is
a revisions the soft exchanges we can
actually apply a suffix to our revision
to make it easily identifiable changes
we make to our container and image
changes and also the scale rule so if
we're changing uh how we're scaling our
container apps that's a revision scope
change
and then for our application scope
changes this is uh our changes to the
configuration of the container app
itself so changing secret values
changing the revision mode as well so
it's not like you're stuck just um
between it's not a hard choice between
single and multiple you can chop and
change as you need to
um how you're controlling Ingress if
you're using Dapper the settings you're
changing that's going to apply to all of
your different revisions
now as the name Will might suggest two
types of revision modes so a single
revision is when only one revision of
your container app is active at any time
so as you're changing and updating your
your container images
um the latest version that you deploy
will be the only version available
um to your container app
whereas multiple revisions is where you
can actually run multiple revisions of
your app simultaneously we can use
revision labels to kind of direct
traffic between different versions and
all of your your revisions will remain
active until you go and deactivate them
now there's a hard limit
of 100 100 revisions available to each
container app because you've got to
distribute a hundred percent of the
traffic if you have a use case where you
want to keep 100 revisions active and
direct one percent traffic to each one
of them
I'd love to hear hear about that
um but that's just kind of like a hard
limit of how many revisions yeah you can
have
to talk about replicas uh the unit of
scale in Azure container is called a
replica
um and this is just essentially how many
replicas are going to be available to a
particular revision of your container
app now one thing to note that when
you're running in multiple revision node
depending on how you configure
um your replicas and your scale each
revision is going to have its own scale
rules so for example revision one of my
app could have 10 instances of that
revision running while if I change the
scale well it's okay to say okay I don't
really want 10 instances of this
application to run and in version two I
Define the upper limit to five
that's going to have its own scale
criteria so if you're running in
multiple revisions and you're directing
traffic to different revisions just bear
in mind that the scale rule will apply
to that particular revision
let's go into networking I'm not going
to go too deep into networking I'm just
going to just kind of like take it at a
high level overview
um
and just kind of explain the differences
between like internal external
environments so container apps running
this container app environment which is
supported by the uh by a v-net
[Music]
um
like I said earlier when if you
don't want to use a pre-existing v-net
we manage that v-net for you but you
don't have the ability to access that
v-net and with container apps we can
have two types of environments we can
have internal environments or external
an external environment it's just
essentially saying okay container apps
provisioned within this environment are
available for public requests and the
environments themselves are deployed
with a virtual IP on a public external
IP address
internal environments have no public
endpoint they're deployed with a virtual
IP mapped to an internal IP address and
the internal endpoint is just the Azure
internal load balancer and IP addresses
are issued from Custom v-net's list of
private IPS
now with container apps we actually
allow you to expose your container apps
to the public web by enabling Ingress
when you enable Ingress you don't
actually have to go and create a load
balancer a public IP address or any
other Azure resources to enable incoming
HTTP requests
and when you enable Inc Ingress
your container app will have support for
TLS termination HTTP and HTTP 2. it
always uses endpoints always use TLS 1.2
and the endpoints always expose Port 80
for HTTP and 443
for https
now your Ingress IP and fully qualified
domain name can either be visible
publicly on the public internet or
internally with inside the vnet and with
Ingress enabled your application is
assigned a fully qualified name name
and your container apps environment has
a single IP address for applications
with external Ingress visibility and a
single internal IP address
um for like internal Ingress visibility
so all applications within a container
app environment with external visibility
they share a single public IP address
similarly all applications in an
internal container apps with internal
Ingress visibility share a single
internal IP address
and our traffic is actually routed to
individual applications based on the
full acquired qualified domain name in
The Host header
now when it comes to bringing your own
virtual Network there's a couple of
things to keep in mind here if you want
to restrict your container app
um you want to restrict all access from
outside to your container app you should
look at creating an internal environment
when you provide your own virtual
virtual Network you need to provide a
subnet that's simply dedicated to The
Container apps environments that you're
going to deploy
uh Network addresses are assigned from
the subnet range that you define as the
environment is created that's used by
your container apps environment and then
once the environment is created that sub
subnet range is immutable
and each revision of our container app
will be assigned an IP address from that
subnet
cool that was a very high level of how
networking Works in container apps so if
you do have questions just feel free to
ask in the end at the end
cool let's talk about logging and
observability so container apps provides
uh several built-in observability
features that kind of gives us the
ability to have an over holistic
overview of our container apps Health
throughout our development life cycle
which helps us Monitor and diagnose the
state of our applications
now there are different ways of
monitoring it depending on what stage
you are at in your if your Dev test
phase so we can access our logs in real
time through log streaming and also we
can actually connect to our containers
console during the dev and test phase
once we deploy our container apps into
our production environments we can
actually use this integration with Azure
Monitor and log analytics to analyze
metrics receive alerts for critical
conditions and View application logs
using log Analytics
so yeah streaming logs are just
essentially a view
of a stream of your containers standard
out and standard error messages you can
access this either through the portal or
or through Azure CLI
and then for the console connect we can
connect directly to the containers
console and this is really useful for
troubleshooting situations again this is
accessible through the portal or the
Azure CLI
now container apps today is integrated
with Azure monitor log analytics so when
we provision our container apps
environment we also include a log
analytics workspace that will provide us
with a common workspace to store system
and application logs that are generated
from our container apps and from the
container apps that are running inside
that environment
now we can query these logs using kql in
log analytics or via the Azure CLI
uh and there are two types of logs that
we can um look at from container apps so
we can read console logs and these are
essentially logs that are omitted by our
application or system logs which are
just metrics um sorry which yeah which
are just logs emitted by the container
app service themselves and I'll show you
how you can query um
those two in in log analytics in the
demo
we can also
um collect metric data so Azure monitor
will collect metric data from our
container apps at regular intervals to
kind of help us understand how our
applications are performing how healthy
they are
Etc these include metrics on CPU usage
working memory how many requests are
coming in how many replicas are active
Etc and what's really powerful here from
these um from these metrics we can
actually use and set up alerts from an
Azure monitor to test against certain
thresholds and I'll show you how that
works in the demo
just to kind of talk about scaling
um so
underneath the hood
Azure container app uses
um the cada Auto scaler So kubernetes
kubernetes based event Driven Auto
scaling
and there are different
um kind of scaling rules that we can
apply to our container apps so we can do
it on HTTP requests there are support
for various different event driven
driven triggers that we can use to kind
of scale our container apps on and we
can also scale on CPU and memory the
important thing to note here is that for
HTTP and event driven scaling there's
support for scale to zero so if
nothing's happening to your container
app you can scale right down to zero so
you're not charged for it for the
container app to run however if you're
scaling on CPU and memory you need to
have what at least one replica active
um all the time so that's just something
to keep in mind
cool so that's enough slides we're going
to jump into a bit of a demo now so if I
change the way that
I just duplicate
that is duplicated well
cool so I'm going to start off we'll
start off real basic I'm going to show
you how we can provision container apps
using a template and I'll show you a
bicep example and a terraform example
because there are slight differences in
support capabilities for both just out
of Interest Who here's using bicep or
arm templates
couple of you cool and terraform you're
all my terrible Muses here ah more
terrible that's cool okay we'll we'll
start with bicep
so what I've got here not this one this
one
so here is kind of like my bicep
template so I'm just gonna get rid of
the terminal so we can get some more
real estate and at the back is that good
or do you want me to zoom in a little
bit
one more
that better awesome fantastic
cool so with bicep it's real easy it's
kind of like scaffold your container
apps environment so here I've got my log
analytics workspace that I'm going to be
sending all the logs that are emitted
from my container apps um in my
container apps environment it's going to
be sent to this log analytics workspace
I've got an app insights workspace here
because it's important to point out
there's no direct integration currently
with container apps and application
insights however within your
applications you can basically use the
instrumentation key or better yet the
connection string just to note that
instrumentation keys for application
insights is going to be retired in 2024
so make sure you're using the connection
string
um if you provide your container out
with the connection string you can still
send logs that are coming from your
applications into application insights
and then you can integrate that with log
Analytics
here I've got my environment so here
I've given it a name I've got my
location and I'm configuring the um
configuring my logs to be sent to log
analytics currently at the moment
there's only support for log Analytics
future Integrations I'm not sure when or
if so I can't really comment on that but
here what we're doing
um we're just configuring
um our container apps environment to
send logs to our log analytics workspace
using the customer ID and also the
primary shared key so it's fairly
straightforward to kind of set up
if I was to integrate this or deploy
this sorry into a v-net I'd also um
configure it without the environment
level as well and with um
with v-net support as well you can
actually make your container apps
environments its own redundant as well
it's actually a requirement so if you're
using availability zones for your
architecture well done
um but you have to provide your own
v-net to do that with Azure container
apps
and then here I've just got a really
basic container app that's going to be
deployed to that container apps
environment so here I'm just saying so
the managed environment ID I'm just
saying okay this container app is going
to be deployed into this this
environment
I'm setting my revisions
um to multiple so this container app can
have multiple revisions active at any
time I'm enabling Ingress I'm just using
HTTP for Target point of 80.
um and then for my container so I'm
defining the image I'm providing a name
and I've got some environment variables
here that this container app
excuse me is gonna
um
it can can use within it within its
application and then I'm also defining
some scale rules I won't do any scaling
within this demo but this is
um we can actually Define minimum and
maximum replicas at the hard limit
for Max replicas at the moment is 30.
um
that will grow over time
when and if again can't comment sorry
and there's also support for managed
identities as well so today if you're
developing Azure functions and you're
using role assignments to Grant your
functions access to a database or a
message queue you can do the same within
Azure container apps as well so there's
support for that which is really good
and it prevents us from using Secrets
within our application as well which is
something I enjoy I'm a big proponent of
so if I'm just going to run that
visualizer you can see there very basic
there's my environment there's my
container app
my app insights workspace and my log
analytics workspace all working together
as just kind of like a basic container
apps environment
one thing that I will add
I've also got within this folder a yaml
file so
it is possible to Define your container
apps
in yaml um files I'm reluctant to use
the word manifests because these are not
your kubernetes manifests anyone here
who's worked with kubernetes can see is
a different kind there's not a this
isn't a deployment I'm not defining a
kubernetes deployment I wouldn't be
using the kubernetes sorry Cube control
to deploy this um yaml file it's just if
you want to if you're used to kind of
like developing your and provisioning
your services
um using yaml files there is the option
of doing that in container apps just
taking my Microsoft hat off at the
moment it's not great
um
here I'm not I'm keeping this very very
simple I'm not defining which container
registry I'm using I'm pulling a Public
Image so I don't need to
um
there's a lot of things in here so like
the name of the container app the
resource Group certainly the environment
ID that I'm going to deploy this
container out to
a lot of those things I would
parameterize
and support for that at the moment is
not great but it is being worked on and
getting a little bit better so to deploy
this
I'll open up my command prompt I'll do a
little bit
of copy and pasting just for time
and with the Azure CLI we have support
for operating against our container apps
using the Azure CLI so here all I'm
doing is okay I'm going to create a new
container app I'll actually increment
this a little bit
because I've built one before and
defining it in this Resource Group using
that yaml file so if I press enter I'll
let that run essentially what the
command line will should do is have a
look I'm not in the right folder
if I actually navigate to the right
folder what it should do
what I'll do is
I'll actually use the terminal inside
here rather chopping changing
and then I'll just CD into bicep and
yaml
copy and paste that
all that's going to do is going to read
my yaml file and it's going to create
a new
um
a new container app
see some of the warnings here saying
okay some of the values are provided on
the command line
I've already been provided in the yaml
file so I'm just going to have a look at
the yaml file and just take those values
instead so it's just something to keep
in mind
so if I navigate into the Azure portal
I've got my Resource Group here
's one I made earlier
so there's the container app that I've
defined in my yaml file
ready to go it's a real basic scenario
there of having a bicep template you can
provision a container up there
and you can also provision container
apps using yaml files you can't
provision container app environments
that are using yaml
so if I was to stay at preference use
bicep there's better support for it
there's better support for
parameterization
Etc
and then to just kind of quickly go over
terraform so terraform has
um
it's doable it is doable but for those
of you who kind of follow the terraform
project and particularly follow the
Azure resource manager
provider currently at the moment there's
no out of the box support for
provisioning container apps using the um
hashicor Azure RM provider
so what we have we have another resource
provider called Azure AZ API which is
kind of like a thin wrapper over the arm
API that allows us to kind of provision
container apps so here again I'm
defining my log analytics workspace
application insights and then here I'm
starting to use the AZ API provider here
I'm providing a type for my managed
environment and here within this Json
encode I'm just defining the properties
for my container app environment and
also the container app itself and just a
little trick with Visual Studio code to
kind of help you with development of
that
we do have an extension that kind of
supports um using that provider and
provides intellisense so I recommend if
you are using this provider do have a
look at this extension it's just going
to make your development
um life a little bit easier
cool so let's take this up a level let's
now look at let's explore revisions so
if I go into here
so what I've got
I've got a application that is going to
listen to two apis
so one API store exposes information of
how much inventory I have and another
API exposes the products that I have in
my store and I've got another container
app that's just going to serve as a UI
interface for that
so here in my deploy folder here I've
got my entire bicep file so again
I've got a kind of my container app
environment up here and I've also got my
container apps that are going to be
provisioned to that container app
environment
one thing to notice here
is again
we were defining a registry so this is
going to pull a container image from our
um private Azure container registry but
I've disabled um external Ingress
into my container app so
these container apps can communicate
with each with each other inside the
container app environment however if I
try to access this container app outside
the environment I'm not going to be
successful
so if I actually go into the portal very
quickly
go back into resource groups
and if I look at I'll take this
inventory one as an example
this will give me a fully qualified
domain name but it's marked as internal
so I'm not going to be able to access it
from outside the container app
environment
cool but what I want to show here is
this idea of revision management so if I
look at this store application
I've hooked it up to Azure app
configuration
which is going to store a feature flag
and essentially when I enable a feature
flag for that particular revision it's
going to expose a beta product a beta
feature to um to those users who can
access that particular revision which is
just
if I go into Pages look at the bay it's
just that it's just going to be a razor
page that we will be able to navigate to
so if I go
into my store
application
currently at the moment I've got a
revision
where this feature isn't enabled and 100
of my traffic is being stored um being
directed to this current version here so
what I'm going to do is I'll just open
this up I'll get rid of you
get rid of you as well
through the power of video editing which
we can't do in a live stage
Let me refresh that essentially I want a
URL
oh
would it be funny if Azure went down
while I was doing all my demos
standby folks
I'd love to blame it on conference Wi-Fi
but I'm using the hotel Wi-Fi
oh dear
I am offline thank you
let me try again
apologies about this folks essentially
what I want to do is I want to navigate
to
my store home page
and essentially we're going to run a
couple of commands to create a copy of
our existing revision
and then we're going to create run
another command
that is
going to essentially split traffic
between those two different revisions is
it developers with just lower case
awesome
let's give it a go
no ass
make sure I spell developer properly
that'd be good there we go
awesome there we go
go back to the portal
ignites running on right now for those
of you who follow Microsoft a little bit
so if the Azure portal went down during
ignite that would be very
unfortunate
awesome okay so back in the portal
go to the store
and I'm going to open this up and there
it is there's my UI okay
so now I want to essentially create a
revision
that's going to have my latest
um latest feature enabled so I'll just
go back into
my command prompt just run CLS and what
I'm going to do just do a little bit of
copy and pasting just for time I'm going
to create a copy of my existing revision
so run through
before I run that
essentially what through the azcli that
I can do
creating a copy of revision I'm
specifying the name of my container app
so I can point it at the right container
and with this we can actually set
environment variables as we're creating
um new copies of our revisions remember
that changing environment variables is a
revision scope change so here I'm going
to be enabling
um my feature that I've got in Azure app
configuration and we can provide a
suffix to it so I'm going to say beta
NDC will
remember that revisions are immutable so
you may deactivate a revision but it
will still kind of exist so if I go
while that's running in the background
if I go into my revision management it
will show you by default
all kind of like the um active revisions
um that's creating in the background so
that's been successful
so that's created my new revision
hopefully it hasn't redirected traffic
to it
okay yeah so it's redirected um 100 of
traffic to it but now we want to split
between the two different
um
two different revisions so in order to
do that we're going to run another azcli
command
didn't copy the eight so I'll just do
that
cool so what I want to do
here is the revision suffix that I want
to split traffic to
so here
what we're doing is we're running a
command line saying okay for Ingress
we're going to send 50 of our of our
traffic to the latest revision and we're
going to send the other 50 to the prior
revision
so that's going to run in the background
and that's going to be that's going to
split um traffic between those two
different revisions so as that's running
in the background
if I just click refresh
we can see there that 50 of the traffic
has been split either way
just let the command prompt do its thing
make sure it's acknowledged
because the idea here is
if I keep on clicking refreshing I'll
eventually hit the page where my Beta
feature is enabled
I've got a nervous eye on the time and
the Wi-Fi which is pretty cool
nothing like mixing up on a live demo
cool so there we go so now though my
traffic has been split between those two
different revisions
so
if I go back into here
should be able to see the traffic's been
split accordingly
so if I go back into my
um store UI
just give it a refresh I've managed to
land on the beta page and now that beta
has been exposed to me purely based on
traffic
that's a real basic scenario of how we
can use revisions
in Azure container apps one thing that I
will note here if I go back into my
revision management if I actually click
on this
this will give me a URL for this
particular revision so if I navigate to
that
it's going to show me that beta feature
enabled for me imagine you're developing
apis and you're deploying them to Azure
container apps what this does it
provides you with an endpoint that you
can actually run smoke tests against so
you're developing an API you've got new
features you've run your smoke tests
against that and if your tests have
passed you can use the Azure CLI to kind
of switch traffic and do some blue green
deployments as well
so
yeah
that's how we can use revisions to kind
of um
manage our deployments open up some
interesting deployment scenarios and
redirect traffic between
um
between those two different
um revisions
now one thing that I have done
for this I've defined a scaling rule for
this particular revision
okay so for this latest revision
I've got a minimum a maximum of replicas
from 1 to 30 and I've got this HTTP
scale rule
so every uh for every 100 concurrent
request to my container app we're going
to scale up by one replica
so
to kind of visualize this
what I'll do is I will actually
assign 100 traffic to you
deactivate you
save that
while that's updating
I am
going to take my URL here and I'm going
to use Azure load testing
to just flood it with requests
so that's real simple so I can just
create a test
here
it's one I created earlier
and just have a hundred users
I'll run it for 60 seconds
and while that's running in the
background
I'll show you what this looks like
within the metrics themselves so if I
navigate to my container app
that I had opened earlier
we can actually
look at the metrics emitted from it to
see
how many replicas it is scaled up to
so around about five o'clock in the
morning
um
which is seven o'clock my time I keep
waking up at two o'clock in the morning
I've got like this weird jet lag thing
going on I can't anyway but essentially
as those HTTP requests are coming in
the amount of replicas that are being
increased will scale up to 30 and then
once those requests start to die down it
will scale back down to our minimum
replica
and then from here
what we can do is we can actually
generate
see if that's running that is executing
that's good we can actually generate
alert rules from that
so taking that um kind of replica count
as an example I can use something say
okay every time it sees a threshold of
um I want to create an alert that's
going to kind of alert my on-call team
that I've defined here and this is a
really good way of being proactive and
making sure that your
[Music]
um
make sure you're monitoring what's going
on with inside of your container apps
now here I'm just using it for I'm just
using the portal for visibility so you
can actually understand how this all
works please do this in infrastructure
as code you can do this in both bicep
and terraform
please get into the habit of
um creating alert rules creating what
kind of things you want to report on in
terms of metrics and diagnostic settings
within your code so if you're standing
up new environments everything is just
like a template deployment rather than
going through the portal and spending
hours and hours configuring different
metric rules for different environments
where you can just deploy a template
cool so if I create that
that's executed
so I won't actually create that but I'll
go back into metrics
and hopefully there won't be
not for you
my store there won't be a a bit of a
delay there is a little bit of a delay
in metrics in azure
but if I look at my replica count see it
scaled up to 30 replicas again
and a little while once things have
calmed down it will scale back down to
about back down to one so we can Define
scale rules within our container apps to
kind of control how our container apps
are going to scale
now one thing that I do want to point
out with this sample
this kind of deploys container apps
alongside the container app environments
um it's log analytics workspace it's app
insights
and in kind of like real world scenario
this is a good sample so essentially
part of my role is we create quick start
templates and samples so that whole
deploy to Azure button we create samples
that you can essentially just do that
but in real life scenarios this doesn't
it doesn't translate there's
um
there's there's kind of this concept of
you'll have your core infrastructure
which would be shared between different
components of your application that I
know that with microservices design you
want to try and like isolate data
sources to each service but inevitably
things and it does make sense where some
resources will be shared such as a key
um key vaults so what we can do using
bicep and this is possible in terraform
as well
uh we can actually split the
infrastructure for our core
infrastructure and also split out the
infrastructure relevant to that
particular content app or particular
service I should say
so in this file this is kind of like my
core infrastructure
so in a container Apps World we've got
our local analytics workspace we've got
our container registry and also our
container apps environment
and here I've got several different
services
so I've got one for my catalog ordering
and web so if I go into my catalog here
I can see this infrastructure
um I've got the spiceps file for this
infrastructure
and these are relevant to that
particular service so here I'm just
using let me get some real estate going
here I'm referencing the existing
container registry that I've provisioned
in my core infrastructure I've got my
key vaults contain apps environment and
here I'm using a module for a container
app now with bicep you can actually
deploy your modules into something like
Azure container registry and this is
what I'm doing here you can use local
modules as well it really depends on
your use case but here all of these
resources that I'm defining in my bicep
template are relevant to my um my
catalog service and this makes life a
little easier when we're actually
deploying our services so if I look at
my deploy store yaml file this is a
GitHub actions workflow file so here all
I'm really concerned about is my
wrong one that's it all I'm really
concerned about is my core
infrastructure so I'm doing some linting
on my bicep I'm validating my bicep
um doing some previews it's good to have
controls and deployment Gates throughout
your deployment so you can actually
control what you're going to deploy
and then I've got a stage where I can
actually manually approve that
deployment
um to my production environment
and the advances of kind of separating
this out here in my core infrastructure
I'm only really worried from a container
apps perspective about my container apps
environment
so by kind of isolating my container
apps deployment in another file another
workflow so this is one for my container
apps workflow
here I'm provisioning the infrastructure
relevant for this service
I'm validating it like I'm doing it for
my core service
and then I'm deploying the
infrastructure and I can deploy my
infrastructure alongside my containers
so once I've built my infrastructure and
it's ready I can start to build my API
containerize it store it in Azure
container registry and then deploy it to
my container app
and it's also good because we're running
tests on our um API projects as well
um before we start building it you can
also use this approach to kind of test
your infrastructure code and also do
some security checking on your um on
your kind of um container images and
scan your container images as well
rather than what we were doing earlier
in kind of like the a b scenario where
essentially we're kind of deploying
everything at once and using this
approach you do run into the risk of
kind of creating redundant revisions so
kind of the takeaway from that is to
really have a think about how you're
going to be structuring your
microservices architecture and just
think about how you're going to deploy
the different services in a way that's
easy to manage and also easy to kind of
retire when you don't need it not
everything even though the
when we think of microservices
architecture we think of oh these we're
kind of building new services for the
future it's important to have
application life cycle in mind because
there will be a day where you have to
retire a service or a domain because
it's not relevant to you anymore
um so by isolating it into its own kind
of domain you get the advantage of being
able to switch on and switch off
capabilities as you go along
so if I go into GitHub for this just
looking for time
don't want to confirm my settings right
now thank you
um so they're on my workflow files if I
go into actions
and I'll look at one that I ran earlier
this morning
here we have the ability to kind of just
look at controlling our deployment for
our infrastructure
and then once our infrastructure is
deployed we can start to build out our
API project
and build our container image and then
deploy the our container image from
Azure container registry into our
container app
just having a look at that that job
takes
10 minutes to run and I've got four
minutes left so I won't make you watch
uh we provision infrastructure
so hopefully you guys get an
understanding of like how um you can
start to formulate your
um infrastructure code in such a way
where you can kind of like split it up
um
into various different components using
kind of container apps
so what I'll do is I'll just kind of
wrap up here
so container apps the aim of container
apps is to really help developers shift
their focus from having to maintain
complicated orchestrator container
orchestrators and really focus on their
application at the end of the day we're
here to build new features that are
going to be valuable to our customers
and our users we don't want to have to
waste time if we don't have the skill
set to worry about things like
kubernetes if we don't have to
and what this does it actually helps us
perform simple application of perform
application life cycle tasks such as
upgrading traffic shifting between
different versions and versioning itself
in a much simpler way than we would have
to when we're managing a container
orchestration system
container apps does come with built-in
observability with Azure monitor today
if you're using something like Splunk or
elastic or anything else
I don't know when or if but I wouldn't
be surprised in the near future those
Integrations would be would be coming
and there's support for internal and
external networking so when you're
designing your um kind of like
microservices architecture do have a
think about how networking is going to
be involved in that it's not like
kubernetes where you have to plan for
how many pods and what kind of
networking plugins are going to be using
Etc but it is worth considering
and then there's also support for kind
of great open source sales projects so
the support for cada and voice service
Discovery and integration with Dapper so
rather than having to look at the
massive cncf project list and decide
which kind of flavors you want this is
provided for you
awesome thanks for listening thanks for
sticking with me when the Wi-Fi went
down I knew something was going to
happen so that's that was fun if you
have any questions
um you can ask me here or you can feel
free to reach out to me I'm on Twitter
or reach out to me Microsoft I'm going
to be hanging around the conference
conference as well
um yeah thanks for coming
[Applause]